si vienen a estados unidos ilegalmente
serán devueltos fue el mensaje que mandó
el secretario de seguridad nacional de
eeuu a los miles de migrantes haitianos
que buscan acceder al país
rey hemos reiterado que nuestras
fronteras no están abiertas y que la
gente no debe hacer ese viaje peligroso
las personas y las familias están
sujetas a restricciones fronterizas
incluida la expulsión y expulsión
mayorkas enfatizó en que el estatuto de
protección temporal un amparo que cobija
a las personas que proceden de países
con conflictos armados o desastres
naturales no está vigente
también dijo que aumentarán la cantidad
de vuelos de regreso a haití y anunció
otras medidas para acelerar la expulsión
mandan de regreso a nuestros valles y
allá no tenemos nada de nuevo todo todo
lo que teníamos
no está bien los estadounidenses están
agarrando a los haitianos y deportando a
todos a haití haití no tiene presidente
no hay trabajo no hay nada
los anuncios sean como una respuesta a
los cerca de 15.000 migrantes que se
habían refugiado en la ciudad texana del
río por lo que cientos de migrantes
varados han optado por regresar de
manera voluntaria a mexico donde el
presidente del país andrés manuel lópez
obrador urgió a eeuu a invertir en
américa central para contener la
migración a pesar de que el presidente
estadounidense optó por revertir muchas
de las políticas de inmigración de su
predecesor esta expulsión ha sido
catalogada como la mayor y más veloz en
décadas